welcome back to a20 special relativity
in this section we talk about the famous
twin paradox it's probably the most
famous paradox in special relativity i
want to get to the bottom of this and
understand
really where
there is a conflicting or contradictory
statement in this story
let me just first say that this year is
personal to me i do have a twin brother
and you can see three pictures of myself
and my twin brother here you know
very little on our first day of school
in germany you get a little box of candy
i mean when you go to schools to make it
more attractive to actually learn and
study and then a picture which is
probably already about 10 years old
so what you can take away from here is
clearly moving clocks are slow it turns
out that my twin brother lives in the
very same village in germany where i
grew up where we both grew up why while
i traveled the world
constantly and funds me on the road
um between france and
geneva and switzerland and the united
states
and again i think there is no dispute
here
it can be seen from this picture that
your professor looks much younger i even
have a more recent picture this is two
years ago the german chris candle market
where i asked my brother to take this
picture
for this class for age 20 and again i
think the answer to the question is
clear professor clutter has aged less
all right on a more serious note um we
want to quantitatively understand and
analyze the situation and we use bob and
alice again in this situation here bob
stays local and alice has a spacecraft
and she moves with a velocity of 0.66
times the speed of light a gamma factor
of 1.25
her travel takes her to a distant star
which is in this example three light
years away
from bob measured by bob
um the journey takes her on bob's clock
five years and the return takes another
five years she doesn't spend much time
she wants to go home as quickly as
possible
so if you analyze this from alice's
perspective we see that for alice the
journey takes four years
and the distance traveled for her in the
spacecraft is zero
okay
from bob's perspective
the journey as seen by alice
is only two point three point two years
long
and so we find that there's already a
conflict if we add the times together
both ways the inbound and the outbound
waste
um 6.4 years is not equal to 10 years so
there's already a
contradictory statement in the story
but
the key to the understanding of this
problem is that alice in order to return
has to change reference frames and there
you do have to re-synchronize the clocks
if you want or add a specific extra
factor and we'll go back to this and we
look at space-time diagrams so the time
as seen by bob is 3.2 years for the
outbound journey and then 3.6 years in
order to re-synchronize the clocks on
the return on the turning around
and then 3.2 years on the return which
makes 10 years and so that observation
of bob
of alice is in agreement with bob's own
clock
all right so we saved the day here so
let's look at space-time diagrams
the outbound journey
is is shown here you see i've got it
in addition to
bob's reference frame i plotted alice's
reference and it makes it easier to
understand what's going on so we see in
alice's reference frame the journey
takes four years
if you then
go back to the position in which bob is
two points three point two years have
passed
okay
so this is
if he
adds the time
at the time when alice arrives we
go back to the position of bob 3.3 years
have passed
and we then turn around
and ask the very same question at that
time and still four years
we go back in the other direction now
to bob
we are already um much further ahead two
points three point two years blood plus
plus
three point six years
okay and then the journey continues and
we add another
3.2 years to the journey
so when alice and bob reunite
l is aged by 8 years
2 times four
and bob aged by ten years
so the question now is
is there maybe a paradox here
is it possible that we
miss somehow that
why
and try to understand why is this
problem not symmetric
why can i not just use
the other reference frame and just
declare that alice stayed stationary in
her in a spacecraft where bob moved away
with earth and then came back
why are those two things not consistent
and the answer is that it's not bob who
has to change reference frame but at
alice
it's alice will have to do this there is
where the asymmetry is so you can argue
if you want that in order for alice to
do that she actually has to accelerate
but we don't have any sort of discussion
of how the acceleration actually went
about it's really the change in
reference frame which is crucial in this
discussion and causes a symmetry between
bob and
alice
you